- Attention, citizens of Gridiron Heights: There will be some new rules this season.
First off, no taunting.
- What's up, football nerds?
- I got you, no cap.
- Booo.
- That was one time.
- We play offense.
- Also, no haunting.
- Hey, man. Great job out there. You're the future of our league.
- [Together:] Ahhhhh!
- F--k you, ghosts.
- Shouldn’t have to say this one, but no cannibalism.
- WOO! WELCOME TO THE LION CAGE! HAVE DINNER OR BECOME DINNER!
- None of your precious little parodies.
- Ayo, this is lit!
- You'll always remember the day you almost caught Patty Mahomes!
- At last, my final form!
And now I'm the perfect QB.
- No shenanigans, no high jinks, no capers of any kind.
- [Offscreen computer voice:] You must vote out the impos—
- [Together:] Bears.
- That child is going to die.
- I knew you were down there somewhere.
- Dear Mom and Dad, I'm not enjoying camp anymore.
- [Together:] AHHHHH!
- TEAMY IS GETTING IT TOGETHER, RAWR.
- GURGLE, GURGLE. CLAM NOISES.
- This year, we’re going to be calm, orderly and boring. The things people love
about football. Thank you.
- Tuesdays this fall on Bleacher Report.
- All right, let’s try another take where everyone applauds.
- Uh, sir, we were live.
- YOU CAN MAKE CARTOONS LIVE?!
Oh, God.